hat vor zwei jahren ein 16-jähriger
junge einen funktionierenden
taschenrechnern minecraft gebaut
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge minecraft sind zwar
habe ich mir heute gedacht ihr seht
schon meine fresse ist im bild und nicht
meine minecraft wird und zwar habe ich
mir einfach gedacht dass ich heute mal
ein paar andere vorstellen und zwar
nicht unbedingt in game sind sondern
einfach facts über minecraft und nicht
über das spiel minecraft ansicht zwar
würde ich sagen fangen wir direkt an ich
habe wieder vier facts vorbereitet also
36 und einen fake der nicht wirklich ein
fahranfänger ist aber der auf jeden fall
richtig heftig ist wenn ihr den wirklich
so hört einfach nur ihr denkt einfach
nur sowas als ob das ehrlich gemacht hat
so nach dem motto ich will nicht zu viel
verraten
ich würde sagen ich fange direkt mit dem
ersten effekt damit ihr überhaupt etwas
perfekt sich meine und zwar hat ein ende
drache in minecraft eine lebensenergie
von 200 herzen das ist mega viel das ist
quasi der stärkste beziehungsweise der
stärkste verteidigung noch mehr oder
weniger so der amok mit der mit den
höchsten mit der höchsten anzahl von
hertz im kompletten spiel zum vergleich
ein schwein hat zehn herzen das ist das
zwanzigste von einem ende 300 man könnte
sagen ein drache ist egal so stark wie
20 schweine nur die dann auch noch boxen
und stark sind und alles möglich und rom
fliegen als möglichkeit zum vergleich
ein trieb hat zombie oder ein skelett
haben 20 herzen also immer noch ein
zehntel von dem was dieser endra diese
also dieser ändert er ist einfach der
beste
demoskopen die hohe game und das ist
einfach nur heftig die zweite sache ist
dann muss ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen
immer auf meinem bildschirm locken uns
für 14 millionen 66 1655 leute kauften
bisher zu diesem zeitpunkt wo ich das
gerade auf nehme das spiel minecraft
jetzt bestimmt noch mal 1000 mehr
das ist ca jeder 500 zwanzigster mensch
der welt der minecraft gekauft hat und
ich meine das hat mir nicht mal gekauft
also es gibt auch immer noch viele die
das ganze krieg spielen und so also
spielen das spiel locker 400 liter 410
mannschaft der welt und ich würde sagen
weil es ja nicht jeder direkt spielt
sondern das kennen ja auch viele leute
von meinem freund kennt auch viele leute
aber keiner spielt ich würde sagen
jeder zweihundertste oder jeder 310
mannschaft der welt kennt minecraft wenn
nicht sogar noch mehr aus dieser zahl 14
millionen kann man ausschließen da ein
spiel ca 20 euro kostet
und wenn sich das halt 14 millionen
gekauft haben kostet das also hat
komplett mo yan bisher du dich die leute
die das getauft haben also nicht durch
fanartikel oder werbeeinnahmen oder
alles mögliche durch die leute die sich
wirklich speziell dieses spiel gekauft
haben hat mo yan 280 millionen 510.000
67 euro und 25 cent verdient und allein
watch hat von diesem geld mehr als 100
millionen us-dollar im jahr 2012 damit
verdient das mega krasnodar drei es
werden pro stunde elf 1537 skins von
verschiedenen webseiten wie
beispielsweise planet minecraft
minecraft forum minecraft skins kinder
et cetera es gibt ja ganz viele werden
da pro stunde elf 1537 skins
runtergeladen wenn man das weiterrechnet
sind das 192 in der minute und 3 in der
sekunde da denkt man sich dann erst mal
so eine sekunde
wie es jetzt eigentlich doch gar nicht
so viel für so ein spiel was 14
millionen leute haben aber ich meine wie
oft ändert ihr euren skin also ich habe
meine lockerheit einem jahr nicht mehr
geändert
und wenn da täglich drei skins pro
sekunde unter gab werden das ist klick
klick klick klick klick klick klick
klick klick klick weltweit das ist mega
krass ich meine warum laden sich so
viele leute ins kino oder warum change
in die in so viele dass es mega heftig
kommen wir jetzt zum fun fact und zwar
hat vor zwei jahren ein 16-jähriger
junge einen funktionierenden
taschenrechnern minecraft gebaut
dieser beherrscht komplett alle
grundrechenarten also der kann
sechsstellig bei addition und
subtraktion also plus und minus aufgaben
rechnen
und immer noch dreistellig bei x und
geteilt also bei multiplikation und
division heißt es die vision ich glaube
die vision außerdem kann dieser
taschenrechner 14 trigonometrische
beziehungsweise wissenschaftliche
funktionen berechnen und was das ist
weiß ich jetzt immer noch nicht aber der
taschenrechner kann
also das wissenschaftliche funktionen
sind weiß ich aber trigonometrische ich
bestimmt auch aber weißt nichts mit
verbinden aber es auf jeden fall mega
krass vor allem ein 16 jähriger junge
und die müssen wir überlegen das ganze
ist vor zwei jahren passiert da war
minecraft in der version 1.2
da gab es nicht alles mit mit block und
gewichteten druckplatten und so sondern
das war einfach nur redstone redstone
repeater und das war's ich glaub ich
weiß nicht mal aufs pisten ski pisten es
gab es glaube ich schon gab es die
pisten ich weiß es nicht aber es ist
mega krass und ich habe auch meinen
linken der beschreibenden cocktails von
winfuture de die haben das damals so ein
bisschen zusammengefasst und da könnt
ihr einfach mal das video anklicken wie
das ganze funktioniert und es ist
einfach mega heftig so ich würde sagen
das war's mit dem minecraft hektisch
konnte gestern nicht hochladen minecraft
wächst kann man sonst immer dienstags
ich konnte notlanden weil ich dann ganz
da nicht zuhause war
deswegen kam dass koerfer mit komm ich
hoffe dass man ein guter ersatz die
folge ist echt mega geil
die findet ihr halt auch auf meinem
kanal und natürlich sagen wenn es euch
gefallen hat dass ich jetzt mal sogar
ein bisschen was anderes minecraft werk
mäßiges gequatscht lasst einfach eine
positive bewertung da ich muss jetzt
auch wieder direkt los und sonst welche
sagen euch noch wunderschönen tag und
nacht so bevor ich es vergesse das
geheimnisvolle geräusche vom letzten mal
wurde er kann von back kraft hd und zwar
meint er das geräusch war ein hand
muskel trainer der aber auch den
unterarm trainiert und zwar war es der
erste der das geschrieben hat das wird
noch irgendwie sieben minuten
geschrieben und zeigt euch mal ganz kurz
in die kamera
das war ein moment moment dieses ding
hier das war das geräusch und das macht
das wenn ich so mache so dass für das
geheimnisvolle geräusche vom letzten mal
das geheimnisvolle geräusche von diesem
mal ist das hier
ich mach euch nochmal vor
also von was ist das ein geräusch jetzt
nicht einfach nur ja das ist das und das
sondern genau was das für ein geräusch
ist sagt nicht in die höhe das ist
gegenstand oder so sondern was genau das
für ein geräusch der retina wenig wieder
neben dem anderen video mal und
natürlich sagen wie gesagt wenn es euch
gefallen an der bewertung damit jetzt
beim nächsten mal wieder drei mach's gut
und scharf